[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning let me begin by thanking
rita clavin for that powerful
presentation i'd like to address several
issues today
first i've always started by telling new
yorkers the facts before my opinion
so let's start new york tough
with the truth
the attorney general did a report on
complaints made against me by certain
women for my conduct
the report said i sexually harassed 11
women that was the headline people heard
and saw and reacted to
the reaction was outrage it should have
been
however
it was also false
my lawyers as you just heard from rita
glavin have reviewed the report over the
past several days
and have already raised serious issues
and flaws
that should concern all new yorkers
because when there is a bias
or a lack of fairness in the justice
system it is a concern for everyone
not just those immediately affected
the most serious allegations made
against me
had no credible factual basis in the
report
and there is a difference
between alleged improper conduct
and concluding sexual harassment
now don't get me wrong
this is not to say that there are not 11
women who i truly offended
there are
and for that i deeply deeply apologize
i thought a hug
and putting my arm around a staff person
while taking a picture was friendly
but she found it to be too forward
i kissed a woman on the cheek at a
wedding and i thought i was being nice
but she felt that it was too aggressive
i have slipped
and called people honey
sweetheart and darling
i meant it to be endearing
but women found it dated and offensive
i said on national tv to a doctor
wearing ppe and giving me a covered nose
nasal swab
you make that gown look good
i was joking
obviously otherwise i wouldn't have said
it on national tv
but she found it disrespectful
i take
full responsibility for my actions
i have been
too familiar with people
my sense of humor can be insensitive and
off-putting
i do hug and kiss people casually
women and men
i have done it all my life
it's who i've been
since i can remember
in my mind
i've never crossed the line with anyone
but
i didn't realize the extent to which the
line has been redrawn
there are generational and cultural
shifts
that i just didn't fully appreciate
and i should have
no excuses
the report
did bring to light a matter that i was
not aware of
and that i would like to address
a female trooper related concern that
she found disturbing and so do i
please let me provide some context
the governor's trooper detail
had about 65 troopers on it
but of the 65 only six women and nine
black troopers
i'm very proud of the diversity of my
administration it's more diverse than
any administration in history
and i'm very proud of the fact that i
have more women in senior positions
than any governor before me
the lack of diversity on the state
police detail
was an ongoing disappointment for me
in many ways the governor's detail is
the face of state government that people
see when i attend an event
people see the detail that's with me
i was consistently trying to recruit
more to
diversify on one occasion i met two
female troopers who were on duty at an
event
both seemed competent and impressive and
i asked the state police to see if they
were interested in joining
i often meet people
men and women
and if they show promise i refer them to
be interviewed
the state police handled
the interviewing and the hiring
and one of the two troopers eventually
joined the detail
i got to know her over time she's a
professional
and i would sometimes banter with her
when we were in the car
we spent a lot of time driving around
the state
this female trooper was getting married
and i made some jokes about the negative
consequences of married life
i meant it to be humorous
she was offended and she was right
the trooper also said
that in an elevator i touched her back
and when i was walking past her in a
doorway i touched her stomach
now i don't roll doing it
but if she said i did it
i believe her
at public events troopers will often
hold doors open or guard the doorways
when i walk past them
i often will give them a grip of the arm
a pat on the face a touch on the stomach
a slap on the back
it's my way of saying
i see you
i appreciate you
and i thank you
i'm not comfortable just walking past
and ignoring them
of course
usually they are male troopers
in this case i don't remember doing it
at all
i didn't do it consciously with the
female trooper
i did not mean any sexual connotation i
did not mean any intimacy by it
i just wasn't thinking
it was
totally thoughtless
in the literal sense of the word
but it was also insensitive
it was embarrassing to her and it was
disrespectful
it was a mistake
plain and simple
i have no other words to explain it
i want to personally apologize to her
and her family i have the greatest
respect
for her and for the new york state
police
now
obviously in a highly political manner
like this
there are many agendas
and there are many motivations at play
if anyone thought otherwise they would
be naive
and new yorkers are not naive
but i want to thank the women who came
forward with sincere complaints
it's not easy to step forward
but you did an important service
and you taught me
and you taught others an important
lesson
personal boundaries must be expanded
and must be protected
i accept full responsibility
part of being new york tough
is being new york smart
new york smart tells us that this
situation and moment are not about the
facts
it's not about the truth
it's not about thoughtful analysis
it's not about how do we make the system
better
this is about politics
and our political system today
is too often driven by the extremes
[Music]
rashness
has replaced reasonableness
loudness
has replaced soundness
twitter
has become the public square for policy
debate
there is an intelligent discussion to be
had
on gender-based actions
on generational and cultural behavioral
differences
on setting higher standards
and finding reasonable resolutions
but the political environment
is too hot
and it is too reactionary for that now
and it is unfortunate
now
you know me
i'm a new yorker born and bred
i am a fighter
and my instinct is to fight through this
controversy
because i truly believe it is
politically motivated
i believe it is unfair and it is
untruthful
and i believe it it demonizes behavior
that is unsustainable
for society
if i could communicate the facts through
the frenzy
new yorkers would understand i believe
that
but when i took my oath as governor
then
it changed
i became a fighter but i became a
fighter for you
and it is your best interest
that i must serve
this situation
by its current trajectory
will generate months of political and
legal controversy
that is what is going to happen
that is how the political wind is
blowing
it will consume government
it will cost taxpayers millions of
dollars
it will brutalize people
the state assembly yesterday outlined
weeks of process
that will then lead to months of
litigation
time and money that government should
spend managing covid
guarding against the delta variant
reopening update fighting gun violence
and saving new york city
all that time would be wasted
this is one of the most challenging
times for government in a generation
government really needs to function
today
government needs to perform
it is
a matter of life and death government
operations
and wasting energy on distractions
is the last thing that state government
should be doing
and i cannot be the cause of that
new york tough
means new york loving
and i love new york and i love you
and everything i have ever done
has been motivated by that love
and i would never want to be unhelpful
in any
and i think that given the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside and let government
get back to governing
and therefore that's what i'll do
because i work
for you
and doing the right thing
is doing the right thing
for you
because as we say it's not about me
it's about we
kathy holcomb my lieutenant governor is
smart and competent
this transition must be seamless
we have a lot going on i'm very worried
about the delta variant and so should
you be
but she can come up to speed quickly and
my resignation will be effective in 14
days
to my team
melissa de rosa robert mihika beth
garvey stephanie benton dana carotenuto
kelly gummies rich has a party howard
zucker rick cotton general libra jack
davies and the hundreds of dedicated
administration officials
i want to say this
thank you thank you
and be proud
we made new york state the progressive
capital of the nation
no other state government accomplished
more to help people
and that is what it's all about
just think about what we did we passed
marriage equality creating a new civil
right
legalized love for the lgbtq community
and we generated a force for change that
swept the nation
we passed a safe act years ago the
smartest gun safety law in the united
states of america and it banned the
madness of assault weapons
we've saved countless lives with that
law
fifteen dollar minimum wage the highest
minimum wage in the nation lifting
millions of families standard of living
putting more food on the table and
clothes on their backs and we led the
nation in economic justice with that
reform
we have managed every emergency mother
nature could throw at us
fires floods hurricanes
superstorms and pandemics we balance the
state budget and we got it done on time
more than any other administration
because government should work and
perform free college tuition for
struggling families nobody in this state
will be denied their college dream
because of their income
we've built new airports rail transit
roads all across the state faster and
better than ever before
and more than any state in the nation
the most effective green economy program
in the nation we did more for black and
latino families
than any other administration we did
more for working families we did more
for our union brothers and sisters
sisters we did more to battle racism and
anti-semitism
today so much of the politics is just
noise
just static
and that's why people tune it out
what matters is actually improving
people's lives
and that's what you did
you made this state a better state for
the generations that follow
and that is undeniable inarguable
and true
even in these ugly crazy times
i thank speaker carl heasty and leader
andrea stewart cousins for their
leadership
and let me say this on a personal note
in many ways
i see the world through the eyes of my
daughters
kara
they are 26 and 26 twins and 23.
and i have lived this experience with
and through them
i have sat on the couch
with them
hearing the ugly accusations for weeks
i have seen the look in their eyes
and the expression on their faces
and it hurt
i want my three jewels to know this
my greatest goal
is for them to have a better future than
the generations of women before them
it is still in many ways a man's world
it always has been
we have sexism that is culturalized and
institutionalized
my daughters have more talent and
natural natural gifts than i ever had
i want to make sure that society allows
them to fly as high as their wings will
carry them
there should be no assumptions no
stereotypes no limitations
i want them to know
from the bottom of my heart
that i never did
and i never would
intentionally disrespect a woman
or treat any woman
differently
than i would want them treated
and that is the god's honest truth
your dad
made mistakes
and he apologized
and he learned from it
and that's what life is all about
and i know the political process is
flawed
and i understand
their cynicism and distrust and
disappointment now but don't give it up
because government is still the best
vehicle for making positive social
change
lastly
i want to remind all new yorkers
of an important lesson and one that i
will carry with me for the rest of my
life
and that's what you new yorkers did
in battling covet
the enemy landed in new york state
covert launched the attack here
it came on planes from europe
and we had no idea
it was an ambush
and it was up to new yorkers to fight
back
we were on our own
and it was war
nurses doctors essential workers became
our frontline heroes
hospitals
became the battlegrounds
streets were still
and sirens filled the city's silence
trailers carried the bodies of our
fallen brothers and sisters
but you refused to give up
and you fought back
and you won
going from the highest infection rate in
the nation
to one of the lowest
no one thought we could do it
but you did it
you led the nation
and you showed the way forward
and how you did it is what's most
important
you did it together
not as black new yorkers or white new
yorkers not as lgbtq new yorkers or
straight new yorkers or democrats or
republicans or upstate or downstate or
jewish muslim protestant or catholic new
yorkers but as one community
one family the family of new york
you overcame the naysayers and the
haters and the fear and the division and
you unified and you rose and you
overcame and you saved lives
and that was powerful in its effect
it was beautiful to see
and it was an honor to
please remember that lesson
hold it dear and hold it up high for
this nation to see
because it is new york state at her
finest
creating her legacy fulfilling her
destiny giving life
and animation to the lady in the harbor
saying excelsior
we can be better we can reach higher
and proclaiming e pluribus unum
out of many one
unity community
love
that is our founding
premise
and our enduring promise
and that is the salvation of this nation
that it so desperately needs to hear
thank you
for the honor of serving you it has been
the honor of my lifetime
god bless you